[Música]
i
hola buenas tardes
buen provecho para la que siguen
comiendo
quiero contarles de donde vengo en donde
estaba y como he salido y adónde me
gustaría estar en el futuro
me creía con una familia muy humilde
con mi abuela mi mamá mis hermanitos
ellos son especiales mis padres
no están aptos para brindar un buen
consejo
ellos no tenían para comprar una
zapatilla para ir a la escuela o para
decirme nos falta la escuela porque es
tu futuro
sino que teníamos muchas necesidades
bueno
esta es
nos dará fotos pero lo bueno
y quiero contarles que cuando era chico
jugamos al fútbol todos los días con
amigos de lunes a domingo nos juntábamos
en el polideportivo de oberá
hasta que una oportunidad se hizo un
campeonato de atletismo en la pista y
nosotros todos los días estábamos en la
cancha con todos mis amigos del barrio
en donde ya abundaban
lo que era los vicios y malos consejos
bueno se estaba realizando el campeonato
y nos invitaron los profes para
participar del torneo en donde fuimos
entre todos los amigos y nos inscribimos
participamos en una prueba de 1500
metros y finalicé tercer lugar como
mejor del grupo del barrio
como siempre descalzos sin remera como
solía andar siempre
los procesos sombra aaron me dijeron
que nos falte a las clases que sea
porque yo corrí muy bien y que iban a
tratar de solucionar para una zapatilla
que yo hacía nos falta y me apasione
muchísimo dije me encanta correr y voy a
hacerlo siempre voy a estar con los
chicos los profes ellos
me incentivaron
me aconsejaban y yo
y me enganché con ellos me estaba
apasionando me estaba gustando correr
que lo que es el atletismo la prueba de
fondo y pero bueno iba a todas las
clases competir en tres carreras más con
los profes con la guía de ellos competir
no ven es un trofeo tres medallas y re
contento muy enganchado con con los
chicos hasta que todo cambio un día
cuando vinieron
y mis tíos de buenos aires y me llevaron
a buenos aires por seis meses en la cual
no aguanté mucho tiempo buenos aires
porque le extrañaba mucho a mi familia y
decidí regresar nuevamente con mi
familia
me quedé con ellos
todo eso con 10 años cuando cumplió 11
años
empezó a experimentar lo que es la vida
en la calle con los chicos empecé a
experimentar lo que es el trabajo duro
de la cosecha de yerba mate
yo
y empecé a ir a los campamentos con mis
amigos y algunos conocidos nos guiamos
por 15 días en el campamento nos
quedamos y me estaba volviendo un
hombrecito trabajaba solo
todos los días no paraba hasta no tener
500 kilos por día y hoy el tarefero sabe
qué significa 500 kilos por día no es
fácil
resulta que
en esas
oportunidades nosotros dormíamos en el
suelo con el colchón hacíamos una
carpita dormíamos ahí los 15 días
pasábamos a veces nos pegaba la tormenta
que volaba todas las carpas y no la taba
muy bien
a veces nos pegaban las invasiones de
hormigas muchas épocas de frío calor
a la hora de invierno por ejemplo
hacía tanto frío que nos llevamos muchos
abrigos muchos pantalones y nos digamos
éramos un grupo de 20 de 25 personas que
trabajamos ahí
una época de invierno que nunca me
olvido me quedo marcado que nos fuimos a
cosechar y de los 20 a 25 personales que
había 3 fuimos los valientes que
enfrentamos a las 5 de la mañana
sin importar los hielos que se formaban
la capa de la hoja de hierba y nos
quedábamos no veíamos la hora de que
salga el sol porque nos congelada muy
frío y nosotros como valientes estábamos
cosechando
bueno en ese lugar estaba en constante
peligro no quiero ni imaginar el futuro
que que iba a tener si seguía en ese
lugar ahí ya tenía lo que es los vicios
ya tenía estaba consumiendo lo que era
alcohol
ahí consumían drogas también pero ese
era mi futuro yo me sentía bien con
ellos
y me sentía bien ahí pero no sabía en
dónde estaba
bueno esto es mis amigos del barrio
cuando jugamos todos los días salían
muchas fotos
quiero contarle que
bueno cuatro años aproximadamente estuve
en esos lugares constantemente en
peligro y
y ya
no quiero ni imaginar el futuro que iba
a tener
hoy en día los chicos que son mis amigos
un conocido perdió la memoria estaba en
el grupo conmigo otro chico perdió la
droga otro chico está preso en la cárcel
y así es el futuro que tienen ellos pero
un día para mí todo cambió
yo estando 15 días en el campamento
llega un fin de semana a pasar con mi
familia
y dije bueno llegó domingo dije voy a ir
nuevamente para el otro barrio para
juntarme con los chicos de la cosecha y
me voy a ir a 30 nuevamente pero no fue
así yo tenía todo empacado mis cosas ya
la había despedido mi familia y le dije
bueno nos vemos sacado semana si dios
permite y dijo mi mamá bueno bueno nos
vemos ya le había saludado y minutos
antes llega una maestra a mi casa y la
educación en mi casa y me dice
chico querés terminar séptimo grado y le
dio pero yo ni cuarto grado termine no
ya había perdido la esperanza de
estudiar de estar en un colegio porque
abandoné el cuarto grado me dijo no anda
mañana y vamos a charlar dijo bueno me
quedé de sepa que mis cosas al otro día
decidí ir a la escuela ya no me fui más
al campamento donde en aquel lugar que
me gustaba estar sino que me fui con la
docente
ella se fijó en mí y sorprendida me
preguntó en dónde estaba que estaba
haciendo porque estaba así y le digo
mira mi situación es así así me dijo
a partir de ahora yo no te quiero ver
más en estos lugares fíjate en tus
compañeros cómo están y pensar eso hacer
tu futuro hoy voy a tener la oportunidad
te estoy dando la oportunidad de estar
en la educación depende de vos hay algo
mejor para vos y dedícate a estudiar le
dije si la verdad es muy buenos consejos
voy a dedicarme a estudiar
y me dijo bueno esta posibilidad me dijo
si te pones las pilas este año esta va a
terminar séptimo grados
y si le afloja este contexto y por qué
no en quinto también me dijo osea
dependía muchísimo de mí
dije bueno me voy a dedicar a estudiar
ella me regaló unos libros me incentiva
me decía dale dale al poco tiempo le
sorprendí con las mejoras y con la
lectura en la escritura en la parte de
matemática le sorprendía a ella ya que
me costaba muchísimo escribir por la
misma mano durísima que tenía no podía
escribir
bueno ese día en 2000 en 2013 terminé el
séptimo grado ese día fue el mejor para
mí yo estaba
en la escuela nocturna y llega a irma y
me dice
austin terminada este séptimo grado y yo
ahí se me vino muchas cosas decía no
puede ser no puede ser me dijo sí sí
terminé séptimo grado ahora anda de
inscribirte a la mañana en el secundario
y en ese momento empezó a caer las
lágrimas y dije pero ya había perdido la
esperanza de estar en el colegio no no
tenía más esa oportunidad decía y decía
que en la tarefa y ese lugar era mi
camino pero bueno el sueño se había
cumplido en lo que yo tanto deseaba se
había cumplido estaba en el colegio y
para para darle la noticia a mis amigos
también
fue mi regreso al atletismo aquel sueño
que se había quedado en el olvido cuando
tenía diez años
nuevamente con 15 años
y revivió el atletismo de mí aquello que
me gustaba hacer
y
este fue mi primera carrera a mediados
año del secundario yo
están dentro del curso sorprendido todo
el tiempo porque me gustaba aprender
llega un profe de educación física al
curso y dice chicos tienen los juegos
intercolegiales de atletismo el que
quiere correr o quiere lanzar puede ir a
la pista está libre
alcé la mano porque me recordé todo
aquellos momentos que corría cuando era
chico descalza sin remera pero ya ahora
quería correr pero con una buena
zapatilla y quería ganar algunas
carreras entonces dije yo me voy a la
pista ya me fui a las pistas ya le
reconocí a los profes me dijeron
agustín vos que te había desaparecido un
gusto verte me dijeron sí y le dije
ahora quiero entrenar para que a los
ocho meses de entrenamiento les
sorprenda a los chicos también
estableciendo un récord provincial de
3000 metros algo sorprendente para los
chicos dijeron en poco tiempo este chico
logró el récord provincial de 3000
metros y ya me fui a la pista de buenos
aires ya empezar a competir allá con una
garra con
con unas ganas de salir a correr a salir
adelante a escaparme este año con tan
poco tiempo ya estaba mezclado entre los
dos mejores del país con podios
nacionales peleando el primer puesto con
los mejores chicos del país y ese año
me dediqué tanto a estudiar ya hacer
deporte que fui elegido como mejor
deportista obereño en 2015
los chicos se asombraron muchísimo yo me
emocioné muchísimo es que no puede ser
tanto deportista que tenemos no era para
que te elijan como el mejor deportista
de ordeño el más destacado del año
fue algo sorprendente en tan poco tiempo
he conseguido eso y era la misma base
sufrida que había tenido me hizo muy
fuerte a la hora de enfrentar a los
entrenamientos duros de levantarme ante
ir al colegio a entrenar a enfrentar esa
época de lluvia esa época de frío yo me
salí a correr igual y así logré los
triunfos se me dieron muchos podios
nacionales hoy es actualmente campeón
argentino de cross
fui representante sudamericano el año
pasado
quiero esta es una foto de un podio
nacional que he logrado el año pasado
este año nuevamente fui campeón nacional
y así sigo este la delegación argentina
de atletismo representamos al
sudamericano de cross en chile por
primera vez viajando en avión
el chico que había perdido la esperanza
bueno se me dieron muchos podios
nacionales
yo les aseguro que voy a seguir
dios me va a ayudar el permite yo quiero
ser en el futuro quiero hacer un
kinesiólogo ya estoy cursando el quinto
año
fui abanderado y
la verdad todas estas experiencias que
viví anteriormente
me ha enseñado muchísimo muchísimas
cosas me ha enseñado la verdad
muchos dicen este chico nació para
correr este chico tienen condiciones
naturales ese chico tiene talento pero
la verdad la verdad es trabajo
trabajo duro esfuerzo dedicación
disciplina constancia
es insistir
yo creo que todos somos capaces para
grandes cosas nosotros nada más tenemos
que tener lo más importante que la
persona debe tener en la vida que es
plantearse un objetivo e ir en busca de
él por más que por más dificultades que
tenga ir en busca de él hasta cumplirlo
yo me planteo un objetivo de ser
cristiano
de ser un representante mundial en
atletismo de cross y sin duda voy voy en
busca de él
así que quiero
contarle que se plantee un objetivo yo
he logrado podios nacionales ustedes
también pueden lograr grandes cosas y
mejores cosas que yo porque ustedes
tienen su familia su mamá su papá que
siempre están al lado de él y le tienen
para comprar zapatillas para ir a la
escuela tienen muchas salidas muchas
oportunidades
así que aprovechen la yo tenía mi
familia de que no era no estaban aptos
para un buen consejo pero me dediqué y
y me he esforzado y hasta ahora sigo
esforzándome y sin duda por más
piedra cayó en el camino yo voy a
continuar hasta cumplir el objetivo y
así lograr estar un día como kinesiólogo
un día representar al país en un
campeonato mundial o un juego olímpico
nada desearle muchas fuerzas y a
plantearse un objetivo e ir en busca de
él
[Aplausos]
[Música]